September where did that come from well
we're back to school which means we're
looking to distract ourselves with some
wonderful video games and look no
further than early access for the
tomorrow children which I will now
attempt to explain to you it's like
Minecraft in soviet russia and you're
being attacked by Godzilla yeah this is
a tough one to explain but you're like
in a sandbox and I can assure you you'll
be mining jetpacking building whatever
floats your boat but you're also be
defending against giant monsters but
you're attacking your homeland you got
to work together to take them out then
you go exploring for materials that will
help out humanity survive another day
kind of sounds like fun and this game is
free to play starting on the 6th on ps4
but if a bunch of children clones and
dying dystopia is an intense enough for
you look no further than Mother Russia
bleeds oh man what's going on Russia
well this side-scrolling game lets you
use guns melee weapons and your mitts to
beat the ever living hell out of some
people in a nightclub for whatever
reason you can use a syringe to take
drugs out of the corpses to give
yourself more health and go into berserk
mode that makes you even more deadly
this is pretty heavy I mean if you like
Streets of Rage double dragon or like
hotline Miami want to watch a bunch of
dead guys convulse on the ground then
this is up your alley you bloodthirsty
animal you go get him on the fifth now I
want you to close your eyes and guess
what this is based on the music
that's it you're right it's oceanhorn
monster of Uncharted Seas no not zelda
not just because of the main character
in the boat and the bombs and the entire
HUD that doesn't mean it's Zelda I mean
look he jumps totally different I mean
there's nothing wrong with taking direct
inspiration especially if the world is
so interested in other Zelda that they
want one right now maybe this will hold
them off but if developers don't want
this to be compared to Zelda shouldn't
have made it so like Zelda man humanity
is not getting any breaks this week we
also get da ghoss which is a shmup about
humanity fighting from the brink of
extinction the developers compared his
game to 80s arcade classics like Xevious
our type and desert strike but this cave
is definitely a modern take on those
it's got 3d graphics and a dynamic
camera you're also getting lots of
explosions insane boss fights and a
killer soundtrack so this one seems like
a winner and it's arriving on ps4 on the
six finally don't you dare even think
about dancing because this is just sing
and that's all you'll do this is a
karaoke rhythm game developed
specifically for preteens who consider
Instagram filters as a game mechanic
forget tha now that's what i call music
albums all your parties will now be
filled with justin bieber one direction
and any other artist selling sex to
young girls you'll want to make sure
your nice lip syncs can't feel my face
by the weekend because nothing says
innocent fun like a song about cocaine
how do we get to this point why is this
a game what are we doing with our lives
this is out on the 6th remember that
release states are based on retailer
listings sometimes they change
you